this morning the American Heart
Association issued a new warning on the
potential health dangers of too much
screen time for kids 8 to 18 year olds
on average spend more than seven hours a
day looking at screens that includes
phones computers and video games the
Association recommends children have no
more than two hours of recreational
screen time each day dr. Tara Narula is
a cardiologist and CBS News medical
contributor chair I feel like this is an
intervention for me at home I've got a
six year old and a two year old and my
family as well
who's did a lot of time using their
screens yes what does this study tell us
so what we have found is that we don't
have a lot of evidence yet to link
screen time to long term risk of
cardiovascular disease high cholesterol
diabetes but we do have mounting
evidence that links it to obesity how
does that happen well we think that
being in front of a screen kids start
snacking they aren't paying attention to
clues that might tell them look I'm full
I don't need to keep eating so they're
sort of tuned out they're being exposed
to food advertising and then the blue
light from the screen affects their
ability to go to sleep and we know that
lack of sleep can play into risk of
obesity so now that the two of you have
both confessed to say yeah we have work
to do how do you even begin to implement
a two hour rule that just sounds so
difficult to do it can be hard and I
know where they're growing up in now is
it you take it away I know but it's how
do you do that the problem is once they
get used to it then you know it's very
hard to say here's a crayons and a
coloring book or Jax isn't going to die
right exactly but no I think the the
point is parents need to be what we call
a media mentor you really need to be
involved in terms of teaching your
children look media can be beneficial
but this is how you have to use it in a
healthy way they need to encourage their
kids to play outdoors to have that
face-to-face interaction to set media
free zones like no screen time in the
bedroom and media free time so let's
talk at dinner and not use our devices
or have the TV on in the background and
then I think they need to model good
behavior that's really important so when
you're with your kids you really need to
be good about putting your phone down or
putting your tablet down and talking to
your kids and being engaged because they
pick up on exactly doing what we were
saying right that we're always
fascinated by seeing little kids I mean
kids that are like not even in school
yet and they're able to I have a game
that's what I roll
yeah and so Common Sense Media found
that 42% of kids under 8 have their own
tablet devices I mean it seems like
we're fighting a losing battle here I
think it's a reality of the world we
live in and that's why there are
benefits to media we can't just say
blank idli that screens for kids are bad
you know certainly it can introduce them
to ideas information current events even
health education that they may not get
normally it can also connect them
socially to people that may live far
away geographically so family and
friends it can allow them to be involved
in school projects and assignments
online that they might not have access
to to get engaged in community events so
there are there are benefits and then
one other thing is for groups that may
feel socially isolated for people who
have chronic conditions kids with
conditions or disabilities it gives them
a place that they can feel connected
yeah but at the end of the day the
parent has to say no no you do you have
to confirm a lot of shout out to public
libraries yeah get all those things at a
public library in your Park but Sesame
Street and PBS kids do have well
reviewed apps and programming for kids
so and they have these things called
bicycles
[Laughter]